this is bigger than me and there are
other people's jobs on the line another
host I didn't even know she had a talk
show but apparently Drew Barry remember
actress Drew Barry she had she was in
E.T wasn't she an ET I don't know what
else she was in Gray Gardens she was in
ET a couple things over the years she
was in a couple movies with Adam Sandler
anyway she had or she has a talk show
now the talk show went off because the
writers were gone and then she announced
that she was going to come back because
it's kind of like Bill it's like should
I take a year off I have other people
that work for me you know not everybody
can just survive forever so she
announces the show is coming back
the cancel machine comes for her that
everybody hates her she's evil so what
does she do webcam video crying please
I deeply apologize to writers I deeply
apologize to unions
I deeply apologize
I wanted to own a decision so that it
wasn't a PR
atted situation and I would just take
full responsibility for my actions
[Music]
I know there's just
nothing I can do that will make this
okay for those it is not okay with this
is bigger than me and there are other
people's jobs on the line
I want to just put one foot in front of
the other and make a show that's there
for people regardless of anything else
that's
all right so first off I have to issue
with second correction her name is Drew
Barry Moore not Drew Barry I think I was
getting her confused with Drew Carey
which she's kind of morphing into him
anyway if you see how insane this is she
did what she thought was right right she
did what she thought was right for
herself or the other people on her shows
their fan you know the other people that
work on her show who aren't just writers
it's all these other people who want to
go back to work but then I have to
deeply apologize it's one thing to say I
deeply apologize to the writers right
like that's one thing to say if you're
the if you're the talent on the show
that's what they call them the talent
you're the front facing person I do I
deeply apologize to the unions that
sounds that sounds like the most sellout
I deeply apologize to the unions there
are there are vending machines in those
Union offices and somebody's got to eat
the kitkats like it just sounds like
such a freaking sell out yeah but all
right lady they're gonna hate you no
matter what you do so oh so anyway long
story short so now her Show's back off
so the show was on then it was off she
did what she thought was right now she's
backtracking on the whole thing her
Show's off again okay